Let's go next to our caller from the eight
three, two area code.
Who's calling today from eight, three, two.
Hey David, my name is rich.
I'm here in Texas and I'm actually running
for the state house of representatives down
here.
All right.
And I'm 28 years old, but young person.
And actually, you know, I just gotta say you're
one of the reasons I got into this kind of
shit, my policy around listening to you for
so long.
But all that being said, you know, I, you
know, thanks.
Yeah.
So, um, I do have a question for you.
So, uh, I'll be honest, six months ago, yes,
we should.
Being in Texas, we're being a Democrat.
It's a very, uh, a delicate process.
Uh, you know, the idea of Bernie being the
nominee was worrisome.
I'll be honest, and, uh, starting to change
my opinion a lot over the last couple of months.
I mean, even down here in Texas, I think he's
got a good shot at winning, um, the primary,
at the very least.
But I will tell you, I mean, places like Fort
bend County, which went blue, uh, for the
first time in decades in 2018 and, uh, actually
was working on a congressional race down here.
So a lot of the folks that voted a Democrat
the first on many years, there were part of
that suburban blue wave.
Um, I still, I, you know, I'll be honest with
you, I still had this concern that, uh, Bernie
being the nominee is gonna maybe not, maybe
not get those folks out to go.
Maybe they vote back for Trump again, but
I tell you, they came on voting just out of
their pure disgust, uh, for Donald Trump.
And while that was good for us in the short
term, I worry longterm, uh, how are we going
to keep those voters?
So I'd love to hear your thoughts on that.
And uh, and again, yeah, thank you for doing
what you do.
I've always been a huge fan of you.
Well, listen, I appreciate the kind words.
Here's the thing.
If you want to talk about voter turnout, there
is no question that a lot of elections, including
most likely the one in November, it's going
to hinge not on who changes their mind, but
more on who decides to get out and vote.
So the question of which candidate will mobilize
versus restrain different groups from choosing
to vote, uh, or, or getting, mobilizing them
to vote or dissuade them from voting?
It's a very relevant question, but the problem
is if you want to slice and dice it so thin,
we'll never get anywhere in the, and what
I mean by that is the following.
It's very plausible that there is a part of
Texas where they don't like Trump, but if
Bernie's the nominee, they just won't vote
or they might vote for Trump.
I, I grant that [inaudible] that
that's probably true, but then there's also
probably a part of Wisconsin where if a centrist
Democrat is the nominee, they'll stay home
even though they don't like Trump, but if
a progressive is the nominee, they will come
out and vote.
So once you start trying to slice and dice
how turn out will be effected in really narrow
areas like part of a state, it becomes an
impossibly complex.
And so my view is we should step back a little
bit.
We should at the top level, make sure we're
running a primary that is not so damaging
to the candidates that it will hurt whoever
the eventual nominee is.
Right?
That's a top level thing.
Number two, let's make sure that the DNC is
not seen as a dishonest broker of the primary,
which could get people to vote for Trump merely
out of anger or to stay home.
So my thinking about turnout is more big picture
than about like, well, what will happen in
Hampton County versus Hampshire County, Massachusetts
if Bernie versus Biden are the nominees?
Because there's too many factors, we can't
possibly account for all of them.
Would that kind of thinking?
Well, I tell you, I probably shouldn't mention,
so the, the, the main concern is, so the Texas
state house is a, I don't know if you're aware
of this.
We're only nine seats away from the first
democratic majority in, uh, 18 years.
So, uh, if we're able, and we put 12 seats
in 2018, I don't think anybody saw that coming
in these nine seats.
They all came very close last time around.
So I'm, I'm, I'll be honest, I mean, I, I
think Trump is probably going to win Texas
in November probably.
Maybe.
But, um, uh, that being said, if you want
to talk about longterm gains be places like
Texas, places like Virginia where they flip
their state house and other States too, where
we're seeing these margins in the state house
level.
And if you want to talk about gerrymandering,
obviously we need concern over the next decade.
I mean, I think, I do think it's something
that we need to be thinking about.
I don't hear enough from Bernie about a down-ballot
momentum.
I hear it from, you know, Joe Biden talks
about the Senate a lot.
Obviously it's important we went back to Senate,
but, um, I do think a lot of these state legislatures,
and one of the reasons we're in this mess
is cause you know, folks like the Koch brothers,
they spend millions of dollars actually not
even that much.
I mean low millions over the last 20 years
to flip these state ledge seats.
And that's allowed up ballot momentum for
Republicans across the country.
And I think we really, as Democrats, we need
to be aware that, uh, I really think the state
houses around the country need to be the key
to at least, uh, providing a fair playing
field for the next 10 years.
No questions, state houses, gerrymandering,
the census, redistricting, a voter suppression,
all super important stuff.
And we'll, we'll do our best to keep covering
all of it.
Rich, I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much, rich from Texas.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding on
phones, don't hang up because diva will go
right back to the phones after this short
break